Away from our,
from Dan price
in some cases,
seasoning to believe that a founding as
possible.
Some people think that it's not possible
to have permanent principles or
semipermanent principles,
but that everything changes with
history.
And so you have something called the
living constitution or a kind of
historicized constitution that the
progressive's first thought of,
uh,
in,
in the early 19th century.
Woodrow Wilson is a great example of
that.
And I,
I think that's a very popular view
today.
And yet,
uh,
when it comes down to crises,
I think people look at our three
branches of government,
the separation of powers,
uh,
the fact that we have representatives
for limited terms,
all these fundamental things in our
constitution and hold on to them
lamb.
And still,
I'm still believe that.